the virginia gubernatorial election is
upon us despite the democrats major
electoral advantage in virginia the race
is neck and neck some polls even have
republican glenn younkin up over
democrat terry mcauliffe the race has
come down to one issue above all the
others education
mcauliffe declared during several public
appearances that parents have no rights
when it comes to their kids education
younken promises to give parents a voice
in their kids education and kick the
radical racial and sexual stuff out of
the classroom so
in his final salvo to virginia voters
what did terry mcauliffe do
he promised to get rid of a bunch of
white teachers
i promise you we've got to diversify our
teacher base here in virginia 50
50 percent of the students in virginia
schools k-12 50 percent are students of
color and yet eighty percent of teachers
are white we all know what we have to do
in a school to make everybody feel
comfortable in school so let's diversify
so here's what i'm gonna do we'll be the
first state in america if you'll teach
for five years here in virginia in a
high demand area i've got to be
geographic or coursework
we will pay room board and tuition at
any college any university any hbcu here
in the commonwealth of virginia
because we all know you can't you can't
be taught by someone who's a different
color than you are you won't feel
comfortable you won't be you know how
you had all those teachers who were
different colors than you and you were
just shaking and terrified all day long
you weren't learning is that what
happened i don't know that was not my
experience the battle lines are drawn
virginians
you want your kids to be indoctrinated
into radical racial and sexual
ideologies or do you want them to get a
decent education we will find out in a
matter of hours i'm michael knowles this
is the michael show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from maddie ice 113
who says the democrats needed a black
man to play a white supremacist that
labor shortage is real
the labor shortage israel man and that's
not even the last dirty trick they
pulled the mcauliffe campaign pulled
another dirty trick before the the polls
opened today
i guess you can't say the polls open on
election day anymore because the polls
are open for like weeks and weeks before
election day now but the real day real
voting day
is upon us and so you got to tune out
all that crazy other noise all right and
just focus in on the real stuff which is
why i would recommend you check out
raycons i
so loved
my rakons i did i loved them
and i'm speaking in the past tense not
because they broke
not because
i got rid of them
because i showed them to my wife
and i shouldn't have done that that was
my fault and then my wife saw them and
she saw the cool case and she saw the
great colors and she saw that they fit
in your ears really really nice and they
don't have little stem sticking out and
she heard that they have extremely high
audio quality and they stay charged for
an extremely long time and you get hours
and hours and hours of listening
now they are her recons they are not
mine
they are hers with eight hours of play
time 32 hours of battery life they are
hers with all those cool colors they are
hers with that built-in mic that allows
her to take phone calls
with the press of a button there hers i
need to get another pair thankfully
though because ray cons are so
inexpensive and right now they are
giving you up to 20 off your rake on
order if you go to buy raycon.com
knowles fortunately i can maybe just get
another pair this offer is only
available for a limited time don't miss
it that is buy raycon dot com slash
knowleskin wles to unlock up to 20
percent off your raycons by raycon.com
knowles there was one last dirty trick
one last dirty trick before
the big election day in virginia
all right you they've been pushing the
racial stuff the whole time
and they're still pushing the racial
stuff and the final salvo from the
mcauliffe campaign was about how black
kids can't learn from white teachers
it's preposterous this preposterous
argument but then the final shot
after the charlottesville
hoax the tiki torch guys sent to the
yunkan campaign after the we got to fire
the white teachers
there was someone who showed up at one
of the final yunkan rallies
wearing a confederate flag on the back
of his jean jacket
wow he's a confederate he's a racist
he's a white now they were smart this
time this guy who the democrats
obviously sent in
at least he wasn't a black guy they did
they made that mistake with the the tiki
torch stunt at the younkin rally
but they made a few mistakes
the democrats who obviously sent this
guy in made a few mistakes first of all
the the confederate flag that is on the
back of this jean jacket was obviously
just purchased it's brand new it doesn't
have a smudge on it there's no dirt no
lint no wrinkle no rip no nothing they
probably ironed this thing on about an
hour before they sent the person into
the rally the jacket itself might be new
as well now ordinarily when when someone
does a racism
you know there's the racism and then the
trends on the internet
what happens
the person who is implicated in the
racism gets doxed their identity is
revealed they're dragged they have to
block their twitter accounts and yet for
this photo
no one seems to have identified who this
person is because this person is wearing
a jean jacket the only thing on the jean
jacket is the confederate flag which was
purchased about three hours prior i
think
collar popped up long hair and a giant
cowboy hat
covering up so his identity is
completely concealed you can't look up
who this person is and then if you look
at the thousands and thousands of people
at this yunkan rally
i don't see any confederate flags i
don't see
this is virginia first of all and it's
glenn juncken it's a moderate republican
who's so i don't even think if you're if
if you are the sort
to be interested in in more
racial racially-minded sort of
hard-nosed politics i don't think
that you'd be showing up to the glenn
younkin rally no one else has anything
like that there's just this one dude
right in front of all the reporters
it's so transparent it's so lame so then
you get these three reporters who just
take the photo of the guy who showed up
in the brand new confederate flag thing
right in front of them
and they push
they push the narrative the completely
false narrative that uh you know young
kittens have
a racist bigot
a supremacist
i think my take away from this other
than the democrats need to get better at
their dirty tricks because they used to
be a lot better at these things and now
it's pathetic
my big takeaway is there there must not
be a single white supremacist left in
america
i don't i don't think there's a single
one
i mean i guess there's david duke
right richard spencer maybe who are
almost certainly
feds guys who like they go there they go
on cnn to play white supremacists on cnn
and
then can you are there any others
if
if there were white supremacists
racist bigot evil nazi whatever if there
were any of those guys actually in
america
don't you think the democrats could
wrangle one of them and push him toward
going to a glenn young rally but they're
going to a glenn young campaign stop
they can't they can't find any of these
guys
so they have to make them up
themselves
speaking of dirty tricks and election
integrity i felt that bill maher was a
little
[Music]
disingenuous and dishonest the other
night oh conservatives really like
applauding bill maher now because
occasionally he attacks woke-ism but he
is still a democrat he is still a lib
and he still pushes for things that are
really ridiculous so bill maher had sean
spicer on his show
and
bill maher took the opportunity
not to discuss what's going on right now
not to discuss
the
relevant political issues to today but
to focus on the 2020 presidential
election and the january 6th
the worst event ever in history and
the big
lie
this was looked at by
people from both parties and they that
people have come down on the idea that
trump lost this election and you won't
say it and if you're you're the part of
the big lie if you or you're there is
not it's or you're part of the
conspiracy it is not a big lie the
wisconsin you're just audit committee
just released a report i have it here if
you're just afraid you're afraid i'm not
afraid of anything better you're afraid
of trump no you're afraid of being on
this yes you are
you're afraid of being time out you said
i've not seen i have not then again i
wasn't on the campaign i did not see
evidence of widespread fraud what i did
say and what i'm telling you is that in
certain states where they sent out
ballots that were not requested in
violation of a law that should concern
everybody but he still lost the election
okay
okay don't worry about biden okay so he
did lose the election trump biden's
president
did he lose the he did it's a big lie he
he wasn't rigged it wasn't it was it was
the election was rigged okay it was
obviously rigged
they changed all the rules right before
the election what do you mean the
election wasn't rigged
of course the election was rigged now
are you saying
the election was rigged and trump
actually got more votes i don't know i
mean just sean spicer's point i don't
know i didn't you know they didn't prove
it in court so it's
you can't say that definitively
was the election stolen jeremy jeremy
boring the god king at the daily wire
made this point jeremy said the election
was rigged
but he doesn't think the election was
stolen
there actually is a distinction to be
had here
rigged is
the democrats
set up everything to give them an
advantage which they obviously did in
pennsylvania
they changed the election rules in
violation of the state constitution for
goodness sakes
by pushing the widespread mail in
ballots
does this mean that trump actually got
more votes i don't know i mean like
i i guess not i don't you know i mean
what it to sean spicer's point biden is
the president
but please do not tell me
that the election was the most
aboveboard election in history and if
you question it you're an
insurrectionist terrorist whatever terry
mcauliffe who is running for governor of
virginia former governor of virginia who
is now running again
during this election
refused to acknowledge the results of
the 2000 presidential election
this election during in the year of our
lord 2021 refused to acknowledge the
results of the 2018 georgia
gubernatorial election and please enough
with the big lie you know what's amazing
do you know where the big lie
was coined do you know who coined that
phrase and where he did it hitler coined
that phrase he did it in mein kampf and
he used the phrase to accuse the jews
of pushing a big lie
to blame german general eric ludendorff
for losing the first world war for
germany
when you
use the phrase the big lie and weaponize
it against your political opponents you
are putting yourself in the position of
the nazis which the democrats are doing
right now and they're so historically
illiterate
including bill maher that they don't
even realize that they're doing it
enough with the ridiculous
shallow talking good grief people
everything is just an accusation of
racism
white supremacy nazism
give me a break before you accuse me
take a look at yourself
i need some relief
i need relief band relief band is the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea wrist
band that has been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more the product is 100
drug free non-drowsy it provides
all-natural long-lasting relief with
zero side effects for as long as needed
the technology was originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve nausea from patients now through
relief band it is available to everyone
they've also got their newest model
relief band sport which is waterproof it
features interchangeable bands and has
extended battery life you may have tried
some cheap imitation of this for like 10
bucks in the drugstore that's not going
to be it okay but this is fda cleared it
is science-backed it is clinically
proven to relieve nausea does that by
stimulating a nerve uh which then
deals with the part of the brain that
controls nausea it's really great stuff
as the holiday season approaches there's
never been a better time to give the
gift of relief make sure that your loved
ones are nausea free right now relief
band has an offer for michael knowles
show listeners if you go to
reliefband.com use promo code knowles
get 20 off plus free shipping and a no
questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com promo code knows for 20 off plus
free shipping
the left is getting more hysterical than
usual with the
the confederate flags and the fake
charlottesville white supremacists and
the big lie nazi comparisons they're
getting
more hysterical than usual
they're now
comparing the phrase let's go brandon
to the phrase long live isis
cnn contributor just did this
asha
rangapa
asha rengappa who is a cnn contributor
and faculty member at yale's jackson
institute
tweeted out quote as an experiment i'd
love for a southwest air pilot to say
long live isis before taking off my
guess is that one the plane would be
immediately grounded two the pilot fired
and three a statement issued by the
airline within a matter of hours
yes
yes different things are different
this is this is just the modern version
of everyone i disagree with is hitler
right he said now it's everyone i
disagree with is isis
to compare
a
pro-conservative
anti-biden chant that's kind of a cheeky
one it's not even vulgar right it's just
let's go brandon haha to
long-live isis
is hysterical
it's a hysterical thing to say and you
you certainly would expect this from
someone on cnn you'd hope that someone
at a
prestigious university would no i guess
you would expect that from them
too these days the point i think that
this woman is making
or i think it's a woman i don't know
actually though i don't i've never seen
a picture of this person and i'm not
familiar with the name asha so who knows
the point that this person is making
is that
the the two phrases are they're both
political
they're both expressing your preference
they're both
i guess expressing some antipathy toward
the ruling party right now in the united
states and therefore they're the same
that the form of them because they're
both political chants the form
is similar so therefore they're
comparable but they're not because the
substance is quite different
this is a problem
on the left and the right
that we we don't understand that you you
saw this most clearly we don't need to
rehash the debate but you saw this with
the the debate a few years ago over drag
queen story hour
right squishes on the right said if that
if we banned drag queen story hour from
the library why then that'll make us no
different than the left who wants to ban
us from going to church
no it makes us quite different because
drag queen story hour and church are
different
yes the form of banning something is the
same
but the substance really matters here
folks okay and the chant let's go
brandon which really means f joe biden
is different than the chant
long live isis
i mean frankly the longer that joe biden
stays in office probably the better shot
isis is going to have
at rebuilding its power
speaking of fighting our wars
senator
josh hawley
filed an amendment just yesterday
to prevent democrats from drafting women
we covered this when it first went into
the the big bill
democrats are requiring women to
register for the draft or at least they
want to
this is
ridiculous
this is
ugly this is unjust uncivilized deeply
un-american
and so josh hawley says we got to take
this out
now there are a lot of conservatives who
want to argue
some conservatives actually will go
along with it they'll say fine women and
men are equal that's fine fine the the
feminists say that men and women are
exactly the same fine let them draft the
women no the problem the feminists are
wrong
men and women are not exactly the same
and i don't want to live in a country
that sends our women to go fight our
wars for us and get killed by terrorists
that's an ugly country i don't want to
live in that country
sometimes you'll hear conservatives
argue this from the numbers they'll say
well women are you know less
strong and their muscle mass is
different and they're not as heavy and
they're not as tall and yeah sure that's
all true also they're women
i think we also need to make these
arguments not just from egghead
accounting and spreadsheets and numbers
but also from justice
also from
civilization
but as long as we're talking about the
numbers there's an incredible
statistic that just came out there's an
ipsos poll
on the question of drafting
women into the military
45
of americans support drafting women
in the military that's as of this august
now that number is way down when this
poll was taken in 2016 63
of americans supported drafting women
into the military
the reality of it might be kicking in
now
in 2016 we hadn't seen a whole lot of
hot military action we've just seen that
debacle in afghanistan where 13
servicemen were killed
all of a sudden i think people are
remembering the reality of war
but then here's the really crazy number
men
who were surveyed favored drafting women
at 55 percent
women favored drafting themselves at
just 36
men were much more likely to support
drafting women than the women were
shows you
the difference between ideology and
reality
okay and also i think it shows you
something that
might be a little bit unexpected here
which is that
when it comes down to it
women are more likely than men to know
that men and women are different
what i mean by that is you look at the
turfs the trans-exclusionary radical
feminists
they're women
they're women a jk rowling those sorts
of people i guess dave chappelle now
counts too but they're generally led by
women they are pushing back against this
megan murphy right at the
feminist current
men don't need to think about the
differences
between men and women all that often
because we're
stronger and bigger and faster even
those of us who are not particularly
athletic just start that's just the way
we're built
women are aware of that
because women have to think about that
when they're going out alone at night
when they're deciding whether or not to
cut down that dark alley to get back to
their car
when they are in a room with men
so much of the metoo movement
talked about how women felt intimidated
even if men were unaware of the fact
that they were intimidating
women know very well
that they are at the physical
disadvantage
when it comes to men okay and so when
push comes to shove when when you get
down to those numbers
the women do not want to be drafted
because they know it's not right they
know that it's wrong
and men who are probably just lazy
either lazy and just not thinking about
it at all
or who are thinking in very shallow ways
or who want to seem feminist and hip and
cool and so they say of course we should
draft women they need they need to get a
little more tuned in with reality kind
of like the women are speaking of women
the biden administration just can't
learn any lessons
the biden administration has just pushed
one of the spookiest
campaigns just right after halloween one
of the spookiest campaigns i've seen
specifically around women it's called
the life of linda
now
the obama campaign did something similar
in 2012 they pushed something called the
life of julia and the life of julia was
this really creepy videographic
campaign where it talked about how
obama's government was going to take
care of this woman julia from cradle to
grave and it was spooky because the only
meaningful relationship in her life ever
was with the government and there was
such a backlash to it in 2012 that they
basically scrubbed it from the internet
i i've tried to find the life of julia
in recent years you can't find it so i
remember when it was on on air
younger viewers might might not remember
that well joe biden's back with it again
the world wasn't ready for the life of
julia in 2012 but the left is nothing if
not persistent so they're going to try
it again
nine years later
life of linda linda here are the slides
linda is a working mother in peoria
illinois she works at a local
manufacturing facility as a production
worker and earns forty thousand dollars
per year she is pregnant with her son
leo
who is leo's father we're not sure is
linda married it's unclear
is linda gonna stop working when she has
her kid is her
what is going to happen okay she's just
she's it's there's linda she's got
probably what joe biden considers to be
a clump of cells in her belly it's weird
that they would name a clump of cells
leo because joe biden supports abortion
at this point basically up until the
point of birth
so it's weird that he wouldn't but okay
fine she's pregnant with her son leo so
what's going to happen
well
joe biden's going to help out once leo
is born
linda is going to receive a child tax
credit of 300 per month 3 600 annually
to help cover essential costs like
groceries rent and medicine
we were wondering earlier if linda's
married if leo has a father who stuck
around doesn't matter big daddy biden's
going to come in he's going to take care
of those things like groceries
rent
and medicine
what happens when leo grows up don't
worry joe biden big daddy biden is there
for leo
as well you can rest easy at night if
you want to rest easy by the way i would
say you should check out my pillow you
know
how much i love my pillow
a lot of people love my pillow because
it's a good conservative patriotic
company they support a lot of good
conservative patriotic causes
and that's true and i appreciate that i
would
use my pillow products if they were
controlled by communist china i would
that's how good they are okay and they
want to give back to our listeners you
can get great discounts on all my pillow
products if you go to mypillow.com
right now and click on the radio
listeners specials you'll get deep
discounts on
my pillows mattress toppers towels and
so much more
my pillow right now is offering a buy
one get one free offer on giza sheets
these are top quality sheets you're
going to love them all the my pillow
products
come with a 60 day money back guarantee
and a 10-year warranty go to
mypillow.com
click on the radio listener special for
that buy one get one free offer in the
geezy sheets and use promo code
dailywire at checkout or call
800-651-1148
get deep discounts on all those other my
pillow products that's mypillow.com
enter daily wire or call
800-651-1148 tell them daily wire sent
you the deals will not last forever so
call now we'll get back to the life of
linda just one second first though
make sure you check out ben today ben is
going to be talking about this race in
virginia really really heating up i'm
also heading down to the national
conservatism conference that is going to
be down in orlando this is i think my 5
000th trip to florida this year every
major event is happening in florida we
will be discussing though the future of
conservatism
a lot of real heavyweights at this
conference i'm not sure if it's
streaming
i'm sure there will be clips and
transcripts and videos released later uh
but uh joram hisoni the great uh great
contemporary political philosopher is is
running the thing
gonna be a lot of fun so i hope to see
you there
meantime go head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe
we'll be right back with a lot more
back to the life
of linda
so this is the new biden plan for how
he's going to take care of of your kid
and you and your the only meaningful
relationship you're ever going to need
is with him
as leo grows up the government helps
cover the costs for his daycare
guaranteeing that linda doesn't need to
pay more than seven percent of her
income on child care
we'll get to the real
troublesome aspects of this in a second
when leo turns three he attends a high
quality pre-k program for free
okay
when leo leaves high school he's able to
enroll in community college thanks to
pell grants and community colleges
thanks to his community college training
leo lands a good paying union job as a
wind turbine technician leo's job is one
of four million new jobs a year that are
supported by president biden's economic
plan yeah okay
hey try to keep gas below like 20 a
gallon then we can talk about your
brilliant economic plan later in life
linda needs home care and hearing care
thanks to president biden's plan linda
can access affordable hearing care
through medicare and leo is able to
afford at home elder care for his mom
okay what is so
unfortunate about
i am not
of the opinion
as so many republicans have been for a
long time that the big problem with this
is it's too expensive
you're spending too much money this is
economically this doesn't make any sense
this is you need more the free market or
something that's not my prep you know
these are legitimate concerns but it's
not my primary concern my primary
concern is that this is so
inhuman
this is so inhuman so first mama's got
to work
mama doesn't get to stay home mama
doesn't get to raise her kids because
there's no daddy in the picture
so mama
that's good she gets to carry the babies
she's got to work until she at the very
end she can take off have the kid
and she's going to get some child tax
credits why so that she can pay some
other woman to raise her child so she
right away ships the kid off to daycare
then then you know that's that's the
first step the second step is by the
time he's three he gets to go to joe
biden school he gets to go to biden
funded
government school
i didn't start going to school at three
i started going to school at five i
guess kindergarten my dad started going
to school at six first grade
but now they're expanding it out i have
a friend of mine sen sends her
two-year-old daughter to school i know
two-year-olds don't go to school
but what this is about
is
removing
the ability to educate your child from
the parent
to
the state
this is what the election of virginia is
about too folks
at different stages in life but it's the
same issue who gets to raise your kid so
in the life of linda the state gets to
raise linda's kid
then the kid goes to another government
school and then the kid gets a union job
and then the great part of the union job
is the kid gets to pay someone else to
take care of his mother
where is the humanity where's the
husband where's the son where's the
filial loyalty where is where's the
family
where's the family there is no family
as the life of linda
expands
as the government program the life of
linda expands the family disappears
there is a direct correlation here
that's the problem with it i don't care
about spending money on school or
it's a very rich country okay it might
not be for long depending on how how
long joe biden's in office but it's a
rich country i don't really care if i
thought that it were good for for
leo
or linda or the american people to have
pre-pre-pre-k funded by the state i
guess i'd be fine with that
or to have these massive programs i
guess i'd be fine with that
the problem is the inhumanity
when conservatives are just right about
everything when we say hey if you keep
going in this direction progressive
you're going to destroy the family and
they say oh please that's a slippery
slope that's a crazy you're nuts
we're right we're right we're always
right hey if you
redefine this thing then pretty soon
you're going to redefine marriage no
that's a crazy that's a slippery slope
argument you hysterical conservatives
are nuts what happens that's exactly
well you know if we redefine marriage
pretty soon we're going to be redefining
sex itself oh you're just crazy
hysterical conservatives conservatives
and oh that's exactly what happened like
five minutes later
speaking of women's issues
uh mary margaret oleghan at the daily
caller has a delightful video out
where she she goes out and interviews uh
the catholics for choice lady
so uh there there is a group called
catholics for choice i got to put this
in in quotes because
uh
the the
group is not catholic the group is in
grave error and is in
is contradicting very basic catholic
teachings and so
you could not call them practicing
catholics by any chance this is a
fake catholic group that is pushing for
abortion underneath the catholic banner
which actually incurs another sin which
is the sin of scandal so anyway a
delightful video out here asking the
catholics for choice lady
how to defend her views
so we represent and amplify the majority
of catholics in the united states who
support abortion rights
68 of catholics in the us do not want to
see roe vs wade struck down so we
thought it was very important for us to
be out here today
what about doesn't the catholic church
teach that abortion is a crime against
human life
well the teaching on abortion has
changed quite a bit over the centuries
as you know the catholic church is an
old institution
and
the fact is two of our major theologians
thomas aquinas and saint augustine
believed abortion was listed within the
first trimester so we're here to tell
catholics that it's more complicated and
the church's teaching on that is more
complicated that's so funny i've never
heard that in my life i've heard my
whole life that the catholic church
teaches that abortion is a crime against
human life and then if you get one
you're excommunicated but and i have
never heard that that teaching changed
that's funny i never heard that that's
so weird by the way i just i just know i
said the daily caller but i just noticed
on the microphone it says the daily
signal so i want to give credit where
credit is due for this very entertaining
video uh
obviously what this woman this uh
leftist activist who
runs catholics for choice what she's
saying about abortion is not true she's
saying that the catholic teaching has
changed a lot and it used to the
catholic church used to support abortion
but now the catholic church doesn't
support abortion and so it's kind of up
in the air and up for grabs that's not
true the catholic church has condemned
abortion and prohibited it since the
first century
since the very first years
after the the crucifixion and the
resurrection
the earliest catechism we have the ddake
explicitly condemns
abortion so that's not true uh this
argument about
thomas aquinas and augustine
also
bogus stuff i'll just i'll just
just to give you the background here i
mean this is an example of of
a half truth or a quarter truth being
perverted to completely misrepresent
one's view of things saint thomas
aquinas believed
that
conception was a process that took place
when when the sperm served a formative
function on the menstrual blood of women
i hate to be gory here but this is his
understanding of the physical
act of conception okay he's basing that
on aristotle's physics which was the
physics they had at the time obviously
they didn't they didn't have modern
medical signs at the time so when when
you're describing the physical act of
conception it was unclear uh to someone
like saint thomas even a great genius
like st thomas aquinas one of the
greatest theologians ever so
the view was that the the sperm acts on
the menstrual blood and then creates
this kind of vegetative thing that is
not not insold until quickening okay
saint augustine has a similar view of
this as this woman alludes to
what we know
with
modern medical science is
that the sperm does not merely serve
some formative function on the menstrual
blood it doesn't it doesn't work on the
menstrual blood at all but that the
sperm and the egg come together and that
the active conception which previously
in the aristotelian world
the aristotelian model would have taken
weeks and weeks
actually occurs almost instantaneously
and we know now again just because of
modern medical science that the sperm
contains
unique genetic information and the egg
contains unique genetic information when
the sperm and the egg come together they
both cease to be and a new being is
formed and that new being is
the first
iteration
of
human life
so we know that now okay
applying the
metaphysical principles of saints
augustine and saint
and thomas aquinas
to the modern understanding of physics
we know that life begins at conception
and you can't call augustine and thomas
aquinas dummies they were operating on
the physical understanding of the world
at the
time but what is so disingenuous
is well one maybe this one this
catholics for choice lady seems a little
confused so maybe she just doesn't
understand what i have just explained
but
i maybe she does understand it
and maybe she's just being a little
clever here
or trying to be a little clever
and maybe she's just trying to use
aristotelian physics
to justify her indefensible position on
abortion do you think this woman
defers to
[Music]
aristotelian views of the physical world
in other questions
or just when it comes to abortion
because of a mistaken view and a
manifestly mistaken view of how
conception takes place
i think it's probably the latter i think
this woman probably says she loves to
follow the science and she's very modern
and follows all the modern science
except when it comes to conception there
she follows the most ancient and
mistaken
science that there is
such
bs the bigger question though beyond the
obvious nonsense that this woman is
spouting is
why
does she want to be considered catholic
why
she doesn't she's a lesbian by the way
i'm not telling any tales out of school
she's pretty public about that so she
disagrees with the church
on sex
she disagrees with the church on life in
essential non-negotiable teaching
she
disagrees with the church on women pre
women ordination
that's another aspect of her activism
she disagrees with the church
on a great deal of things a great number
of things
so why does she want to why can't she
just be
i don't know what category she would put
herself leftist for choice
why can't she just be regular old
leftist who disagrees with the catholic
faith
for abortion
because because
the catholic church
is the
fundamental institution in the west even
if you're protestant even if you're
agnostic even if you're atheist the
church formed the west
okay the church endured from antiquity
into modernity
no other organizations or institutions
in the west can claim that
okay it is
it is the west
this hillary bellock put it the faith is
europe europe is the faith right it is
the west
and so if you want to transform the
civilization you've got to get to the
heart of it
and i suspect this woman has a natural
longing
she just she wants
she wants all the good stuff that comes
with the faith
but she doesn't want
the things that are necessary to the
faith she doesn't want to make those
decisions she doesn't want to tamp down
her basis appetite she doesn't want to
circumscribe her her individual autonomy
she's trying to have it all
but you can't have it all you have to
make
choices you have cert you have to make
certain
exclusions
speaking of abortion an ohio city has
just voted to make abortion a crime
the city council of mason which is just
north of cincinnati voted on monday last
it was last monday to criminalize
abortion council members voted four to
three
to make the city quote a sanctuary for
the unborn
now mason does not currently have any
abortion clinics within the city limits
uh the people who push for this ban said
that now that there is a ban no abortion
clinics would be put into the city so i
like that as a preventative measure
some people will say that
the city has no right to ban abortion
abortion is a federal
right that was discovered in the
constitution in 1973 i guess written
invisible inc
you'll hear leftists make that argument
and some kind of squishy types will make
that argument too well you know look i
don't i don't agree with the supreme
court's decision roe versus wade but but
we can't just go around uh you know
contradicting the chord we need to fight
it and yeah okay whatever i think this
is a great idea i think this is terrific
love it
keep it up ohio keep it up mason
they were they were right on just about
every aspect of this first
to use the left's sanctuary hypocrisy
against them the left loves to violate
federal law and create sanctuary cities
for
illegal aliens
for foreign nationals who are living in
our country and contravention of our
laws
but
they won't do it for innocent little
babies
they are
in mason standing up
for what is right what is truly right
defending the right of life for the
unborn
and
they're going on the offense politically
that's almost the most important part
here
it's not as important obviously that the
ban itself is very important saving
these lives in the future is very
important but going on offense
politically is something that we could
all learn from why are we always
reacting to the left you're going to
redefine marriage you're going to
redefine sex you're going to change the
bathrooms you're going to upend our
culture you're going to ban certain
speech you're going why stop doing that
to us stop how about we start doing some
things
how about we start setting the standards
and the taboos
how about
how about we start using our political
power
i'll be discussing this later today the
national conservatism conference in
orlando
some people are getting tough some
people are standing firm
student at yale law school is doing that
which is really wonderful to see
we covered this story a week or two ago
want to follow up on it though there was
a yale law student
who
sent out a letter he's a member of the
federalist society which is a
at least somewhat conservative law
society
he happens to be native american student
he sent out a letter inviting people to
a party and because he's a conservative
because he's in the federalist society
some people read the letter and
pretended that it was racist or bigoted
or whatever
i think he made a pop culture reference
to a trap house
which is a perfectly ordinary pop
culture reference and
this was then used by leftists on campus
to say he's racist you're not allowed to
use that phrase trap house or what i
mean they were just looking for an
excuse and so he was called in by the
diversity deans
and the diversity deans said the student
recorded it thankfully so we had the
recording the diversity dean said listen
uh you were just accused of racism and
it's not as bad for you as it would be
for a white guy because you're native
american but look you should just
apologize we don't think you did
anything wrong obviously didn't you
didn't do anything wrong but look you
don't want your
career to be hurt you don't want your
life on campus to be hurt you don't want
people to start saying things about you
you don't want to be called a racist so
here's what you're gonna do you're gonna
here's a letter we drafted up of an
apology look we think it's bogus you
should have nothing to apologize for but
we drafted it up anyway and you're gonna
sign it okay
and this student
said no the student said no i'm not
gonna sign it
he has now said quote instead an apology
should be a sincere expression of
remorse and admission of fault the yale
administrators did not believe i had
been racist by using the phrase trap
house but it did not matter they urged
me to placate students via public
submission i don't believe that the now
common ritual of compelled apology
complete with promises to grow and do
better their words but ones
i'm sure you've seen many times before
helps anyone or is even intended to if
we continue to indulge this culture of
performative denunciation the very idea
of an apology will lose its meaning
great great point
great great point
what the yale administrators are saying
is that an apology is no big deal oh
it's no big deal look you didn't do
anything wrong really but you know these
kids are offended and look you don't
want to hurt your career so just do it
just sign just sign the letter we we
spent a long time drafting for you just
sign it it's not a big deal when you
just move on it's not a big deal
if it's not a big deal
why are the
yale diversity administrators
so dead set on this kid signing
if it's not a big deal
why are these thugs these diversity
inclusion and equity thugs
threatening this kid's career
if he doesn't sign if it's not a big
deal
because it is a big deal
this is like when
leftists say or even some squish
conservatives say
oh just just use the wrong pronouns
yeah the guy the guy is a guy and he
thinks he's a woman and that's
ridiculous but just call him her what's
the big deal i don't know what's the big
deal why
if it's not a big deal
why are you so
insistent that i use the word
don't worry it's not a big deal so it's
cool so i'll call him him you can call
him her if you want to and that's fine
no no it is a big deal
because words carry whole
premises
why do they want it so and the idea of
an apology will lose its meaning i mean
the kid makes a good point too as the
late roger scrutin pointed out
society in many ways runs on
apologies
or our ability to apologize to one
another and have that apology accepted
is a good measure of the health of
society
because it requires something of both
parties when i apologize
when i ask forgiveness i am
sacrificing my pride
i'm admitting that i did something wrong
when you accept my apology you are
sacrificing your resentment
both of those things are valuable to us
okay but then you do it and then you
move move along together
in society
but we're we're not really allowed to do
that anymore and young people are being
really
perverted with this kind of illogic i
have to get to a story this really
shocked me
speaking of young people
a mother
has apparently locked her kid up
in the house effectively locked her kid
up in the house since the start of the
15 days to slow the spread almost 600
days ago the mother just posted a video
to tick tock or instagram reels or one
of those
where
she has the the little kid the
nine-year-old daughter read the news
that the kids can now get the vaccine
and the kid
almost breaks down in tears
this is my daughter hi
she's nine
we're about to blind react to something
okay what does that say
hold on dear
what does it say
vaccine for kids is
so next week should be clear for kids to
5 to 11.
what does that mean for you i can
go with my friends yeah
i can finally you know go outside
go to stores
i'm excited
i'm excited
i thought i was gonna be like in a
couple months no probably
she's white you need to get vaccinated
okay
she's why i need to get vaccinated
the
the girl who statistically
faces
an almost zero percent risk from the
coronavirus
a girl in an age group
that has an infection fatality rate of
of
anywhere from point zero zero three
percent to point zero zero one percent
is why i need to get vaccinated even
though the vaccine does not prevent me
from transmitting the virus according to
the cdc according to the cdc
at the end of july that's why the
vaccinated people are now supposed to
keep wearing the masks that's why we're
told the vaccine protects you against
hospitalization and death but does not
necessarily prevent you from contracting
or transmitting the virus
that that the girl who is least
at risk from the coronavirus that you
have locked up in a house for almost 600
days
who is now giddy and hugging you because
you might let her go outside next week
that is
madness
and that is a form of child abuse
that our politicians
have
pushed upon us and that gullible and
cowardly and sick people have accepted
and that i know it seems a little
disconnected that is what this race in
virginia is about
okay the race in virginia
is about how we raise kids
do we raise them with
the crazy racial theories and the sexual
theories and crt and the vaccine
craziness and the
the covid neurosis
and the public health tyranny and the
locking them away in a hermetically
sealed cage
and do whatever the state says or do we
raise them
more in line with tradition more in line
with human nature more in line with our
own religious lights which way which way
virginians which way america i'm michael
noel's the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
today on the ben shapiro show terry
mcauliffe faces the music in virginia
encounters by playing the race card plus
joe biden falls asleep during a vital
climate change conference that's today
on the bench bureau show give it a
listen